من امس جواز سفر الرئيس المصري الراحل
انور السادات متصدر الاخبار والعناوين من
بعد ما شافوا الناس صوره الجواز وهو معروض
على موقع مزادات هاريج الامريكي وتم بيعه
في المزاد العلني هناك الناس من بعد ما
شافت صور الجواز انصدمت في حاله جدل كبير
وصارت ازمه نقدر نسميها ازمه جواز سفر
السادات فالناس صارت تتساءل كيف وصل
الجواز لامريكا وكيف بيتم بيعوف مزاد علني
ومين اللي مسؤول عن هذا الشيء وطبعا نفسه
الاسئله طرحوها عائله السادات اللي ما
اختلفت رده فعلهم كمان على الموضوع عن
الناس وكمان نتفاجئوا باللي شافوه
واعتبروا اهانه للعائله وللشعب المصري ككل
وطالب السلطات المصريه بمحاسبه المتورطين
والمسؤولين وعلى فكره اللي بيفتح موقع
المزاد الرسمي بيشوف صور جواز انور
السادات مكتوب انه نباع في 22 فبراير
مقابل 74 الف دولار او 47 الف او عفوا 47
الف دولار والنص وما زالت الناس بتزايد
عليه عشان تشتري من اللي اشتراه بالسبعه
واربعين الف والمبلغ الان في المزايده
تخطى الواحد وسبعين الف
طيب على فكره جواز سفر السادات اللي تم
اصداره في 19 مارس سنه 74 وطل ساري
المفعول حتى 18 مارس 81 ومكتوب عليه
بالذهب باللغتين العربيه والفرنسيه
جمهوريه مصر العربيه جواز سفر دبلوماسي
اسره الراحل مثلها مثل كثير من الناس
بتسال كيف وصل جواز سفر السادات لموقع
المزادات هذا خاصه مقتنيات الرئيس الراحل
موجوده فقط يعني عند اسرته يا اما في متحف
والقريه الفرعونيه ومكتبه الاسكندريه
مكتبه الاسكندريه على فكره ردت وقالت انه
هي عندها صحيح مقتنيات للسادات استلمتها
من زوجته الراحله جيهان لكنها كانت عن بعض
الاوسمه والنياشين والسيوف والدروع
والبدله الشهيره اللي كان بيرتديها وقت
اغتياله في حادث المنصه وبعد الوثائق اللي
كتبها ايضا بخط يده وانه ما كان في ابدا
جواز سفر بين المقتنيات اللي عندهم ولكن
اللي اثار الجدل اكثر هو انه متحف السداد
الموجود في مكتبه الاسكندريه كان نشر في
2018 على صفحه الفيسبوك صور لجواز سفر
الرئيس الراحل وتم حذف المنشور مؤخرا من
على الصفحه